If you are interested in an African experience,...
...watching the Homowo Festival is recommended.
People on the southeast coast of Ghana celebrate this harvest festival for a week in August.
Homowo means "making fun of hunger."
According to oral history, the origin of the event goes back a long time...
...when a terrible drought caused a deadly famine.
Once the catastrophe subsided and food became plentiful again,...
...the people from the Ga tribe started festivities in which they ridiculed hunger.
A priest sprinkles a sacred concoction on the royal family to keep away evil spirits.
One day is dedicated to twins who proudly parade through the town wearing white calico clothes.
To add excitement, there is a boat race between different warrior groups.
Food is sprinkled on the ground to show appreciation to the gods.
All events are interspersed with a lot of drumming and dancing.
Don't you feel tempted to go and see this fun festival?